hey this is dr. John Delaney with Ramsey
Network so we're talking about loss
we're talking about grief we're talking
about this hurricane blizzard crap storm
that has hit us suddenly landed and now
it's suddenly start to take off and
we're left with this hole in the last
video we talked about three things that
we have to do number one you've got to
give yourself permission to grieve you
got to feel the loss whether it's big or
small number two you've got to give
those around you permission to grieve
and I don't care if you lost somebody
and they lost prom loss is loss and pain
is pain and number three you can't
compare grief everybody's hurting
everybody's trying to figure out what
next steps are going to look like
millions of people are out of jobs
some people are have really successful
businesses that are booming right now
everyone's figuring it out we cannot go
about comparing grief and then I've got
folks reaching out saying alright thanks
dude real cool what I do now because
I've gave myself permission to grieve I
gave those around me permission to
grieve and what's all this like stuff
I'm feeling it's coming out of here it
yeah I do those are called feelings they
are called feelings and they saw [ __ ]
right and we live in a culture that has
smashed them down in hidden them we've
pathologized everything pathology just
means we've made it a medical issue that
is bad so many times over the last 10-15
years a student has come in and said hey
my parents just got divorced suddenly
out of the blue my dad just left my mom
and I've got depression and I would say
no you don't you've got this feeling
called sadness and when your parents get
divorced you're supposed to be sad or
I've got three finals tomorrow and then
my friend just called and said they're
suicidal
I've got anxiety you don't you're
frustrated you're nervous you're scared
all those feelings are normal and so
when we're sitting here in these moments
suddenly everything that we knew we were
comfortable with that we understood
about our world just hoosh went away
baseball played through the world wars
and baseball got can
for crying out loud we did Easter at
home by ourselves nothing makes sense so
what do we do with these feelings these
marking number one you've got to write
your feelings down and I know that
sounds cheesy and that sounds lame dude
I am a Texan with a lifetime hunting
pass I get it
it's not supposed to have feelings and
I'm especially not supposed to write
them down in counseling there's this
idea called leakage and that's a gross
word they usually only referring to kids
diapers but it also works in counseling
too if you have feelings if you've got
pain and you don't deal with it it will
deal with you and it usually deals with
you at a real inopportune time our
friend dr. Henry cloud says feelings
have a high rate of resurrection that's
a much classier way of saying they will
leak all over you
vessel vandal Koch says the body keeps
the score
our bodies are cells our brain chemistry
holds grief it holds trauma and it holds
pain and if you don't do things to deal
with it it will deal with you so what
did we do
number one you have to acknowledge your
feelings you got to just say I'm out
loud number two you got to write them
down number three you got to get with
the community and process them that
could be a one-person community just
given with somebody else
that can be with a zoom call that can be
with your small group of church that can
be with your buddies you have gotta do
it with somebody else you have to
process grief as a community with other
people and then number four you got to
go be brave now what does being brave
look like that sounds ridiculous like
we're gonna paint our faint faces blue
and then get on a horse that's not what
I'm talking about being brave means
getting really creative my son lost his
10th birthday and my wife created this
magical event of a day that was like a
scavenger hunt neighbors coming out
honking
a zoom collection of his wackadoo
buddies all sorts of things that we had
to go figure out and get creative you
saw John Krasinski doing the
the the happy news network right doing
prom for everybody from home I saw dads
dancing with their daughters in the
living room dad's had dressed up in
suits and they did a mini prom at home
is it gonna be as cool as a real thing
no are they gonna remember it in 50
years absolutely yes being brave looks
like working three jobs because you just
got furloughed and you don't know what
tomorrow's gonna look like being brave
means sitting down with your ten year
old son and saying I am kind of scared I
don't know what tomorrow looks like and
here's what a scared dad does being
brave means talking to your husband and
saying I'm really nervous can we make a
plan together today
being brave and creative means taking a
30 or 50 year view on this because in 40
years 50 years your kids not gonna
remember the algebra you tried to get
through they are gonna remember when mom
lost it and smashed all the wine glasses
because she couldn't get the stupid math
problem right taking a long view on this
deal not trying to to win today trying
to love today trying to process today
trying to be brave today we got to feel
our feelings we gotta sit in them don't
bathe and I'm got a processing with a
community then they got to go be brave
thank you so much for watching today if
you want to learn more about grief about
feelings click the link below I've got
an article at Dave Ramsey calm it'll
take you there you don't forget to
subscribe to the show that's also down
there's just a whole bunch of stuff
underneath this write but don't forget
to subscribe to the show follow me at
John Bologna and I will see you soon
take care